it's finally Time to Say Goodbye the
next valerant update is going to see
changes to the game's map Pool yes the
historically complicated ice box is
finally coming back with some
anticipated changes but Haven the most
iconic most popular and maybe even best
map in the game is out which has got a
lot of people asking one question
[Music]
why we last saw an update to valerent
map back in August of last year with the
addition of Sunset and a reworked Breeze
along with the benching of Pearl and
fracture in the months since fans have
been patiently waiting for another
shakeup to the rotation maybe more so
than usual sure Sunset is fine but the
changes made to Breeze haven't
necessarily changed people's opinion of
it in fact some people think it's even
worse now but more on that later plus
with ISO being a pretty damn fun
addition to the roster and a new gun on
the horizon getting some love for the
map Pool has shot up in the communities
prior priority list much to the joy of
all 12 of us ice box lovers out there it
is now back but to the surprise of
pretty much everyone Haven is out now
although some actually embraced Haven
getting a break or have been straight up
confused ever since it was leaked last
week and it's understandable Haven is
one of if not the OG valerant map it's
been around since the beta and it's
honestly what I think of when I think of
the game on top of that there are other
maps that could have and maybe should
have been cycled out first primarily
Ascent now to get it out of the way I
don't think Ascent is a bad MAP in fact
I think it's a very good map it's just
gotten a little bit boring in Pro play
it can be an absolute slog to watch for
quite some time now it's been pretty
much the same comp with little to no
experimentation jet KJ Omen SOA KO both
teams same lineups same executes over
and over and over again in my own
personal matchmaking it's a little
played out too sometimes feels like the
sweatiest map in the rotation and
honestly this is purely anecdotal but it
feels like the odds of me getting ran
through by a five step attack is a lot
higher here in defense of Haven you
could pretty much say the opposite sure
it's even older and by no means perfect
but it almost always feels unique and in
terms of pro play sees some of the most
agent variation the third site just
works so well here it opens up so many
more options for rotations defending and
attacking without it feeling too
overwhelming in any given round and
being the first map that I ever saw or
played it just feels like home sort of
like dust to so why did they take it out
and why instead of a scent honestly my
best guess is age both maps have never
been removed from the game and since
Haven was in the beta it edges out ever
so slightly now is this a massive Earth
shattering deal no to compare again dust
two has been taken out put back in and
taken out again and no one has ever died
realistically Ascent is probably next in
line and hey maybe it's true what they
say an absence does make the heart gr
fonder now does that make removing Haven
a good idea well given their recent
track record with maps that's a little
hard to say like I mentioned before I
like many others are aren't big fans of
the reworked Breeze and they remove
Pearl right after making some pretty
solid changes to it also I've seen those
leaked proposed changes to lotice and
quite frankly they look like on a
map that I already don't like I suppose
we'll just have to wait and see when the
new ice box drops with season 8 next
week listen that map has been through a
lot and if they can make everyone okay
with it that's a pretty damn good
achievement in my opinion now all this
doesn't mean that they're going to make
some massive changes to Haven in fact I
don't think they're going to touch it at
all outside of maybe a few visual tweaks
but given their recent track record with
maps anything is possible with all that
said I want to know what you guys think
was removing Haven a mistake should it
have been a scent and how pumped are we
that we're finally getting ice box back
statistically speaking there should be
like three of you who are happy New Year
everyone this is my first time back
since the New Year it's 2024 I don't
have any resolutions per se I pretty
much do everything perfect the first
time I try my body's a temple my brain
is perfectly
fine um
it